okay welcome everyone it's the meeting
of the northeast irish district
council's cabinet it's the 9th of
september 2021
um with me in the room is councillor
carolyn renick and councillor charlotte
cupid i'm council alex dale i'm the
leader of the council we also have mrs
sarah sternberg the monitoring officer
and nicola carver who's the governance
manager and then on screen we have uh
council powell
uh
lee hicken cass drury jill callingham
alan marr and tina i'm sorry there's a
there's a
notice in the way and i've forgotten you
you've got a new surname teen roots
out of it yeah there's something in the
way sorry anasha bond he's one of the
government's officers as well so welcome
everyone uh first item is uh apologies
for absence uh we have apologies from uh
councillor parkin who is on annual leave
and away at the moment uh jane dethick
who's been um ably stood in for by tina
um and councillor kenyon is trying to
get down here but he's stuck in traffic
so
may not be with us and i think that's it
so far unless there's any others alan
and on received chair okay thank you
and then declarations of interest i
don't think there's any from my
perspective are there any others to
record
no okay thank you
uh minutes the last meeting um i'll
happily propose them as a true and
accurate record we have a second
okay thank you cancer cupid all those in
favor
okay
and then the next paper is
council plan targets performance update
so i'll hand over to
kath who's going to just talk us through
the highlights of this paper
okay thanks chair so as you can note on
the covering report that's the status of
this split between the targets so
uh good to see this time that fewer
targets have been affected by covid and
when we expected q2 for
even fewer targets to be affected now
that the restrictions came off during q1
uh approximately uh
over half the target's on track and
quite a few have been achieved this time
so
i think it's fair to say the corporate
plan targets are progressing nicely
uh the report covers this the uh split
between the council aims and you'll note
there are three targets in total that
have been flagged as alert uh just to
reassure cabinet that all these targets
are in hand
as you'll note from the commentary
provided in the appendix uh so the first
one is
eco 20 and that's to do with the tourism
um post and the review of economic
development and that's expects to be
signed off at q2 that's gone through and
been approved
and the other one is under
um
environment 08 and that's a climate
change strategy
by april 21 you'll see from the update
as well that both councillor powell and
kenya know contributed to that piece of
work and that's uh continuing so i
expect that hopefully won't be far off
completion by about q2
and then the last one is uh the council
petition scheme
uh which uh we know was uh
behind schedule but we
agreed to keep it as
overdue uh for the
purpose of this report but we are
working to an extension in december just
by way of update from the commentary
provided in the appendix this was due to
go to standards committee in september
but that meeting has been cancelled so
it will be going to standards committee
in november so that's just for members
attention there
and we've also got an out turn on this
report as well regarding um
voluntary and community organization so
res 21
i also know you've got a separate report
on today so you'll be getting a lot more
information on this agenda regarding
this item but you can see from the out
turn there just under 18 000
vulnerable and disadvantaged households
have been assisted
uh through
the grant funding that the council makes
that's actually below target which is
unusual because usually this exceeds
target uh but you'll note there that
cobies had quite an impact on this
target so there's obviously still been
plenty of
advice and reassurance given to people
and support but i think kobe has meant
that some people who normally would
prefer face-to-face contact may have not
come forward during the cobit
uh time at the height of the
restrictions and because of the
government support that's actually meant
some people have not needed that advice
that they would normally seek regarding
mortgage arrears and evictions and that
type of thing so it's it's have some
strange knock-on effect on that target
but you remember i've got a separate
report just after my item so there'll be
more detail from the officer there
and i think that the only other thing to
know is the other recommendation
regarding
um
increase social media posts so um this
is really well established now the comms
department are regularly exceeding this
target every month
usually in except about 300 social media
posts so it's now really embedded as
part of that service it's part of what
they do
and we've now got a service level
indicator to monitor this so it doesn't
fall off members radar it will still be
reported through the quarterly
performance reports but i don't think we
probably need to keep it now as a
council plan target because it is
embedded and business as usual so that's
just a bit of explanation around the
second recommendation
and that concludes my report share
okay thanks very much kath um yeah on
the whole it looks uh looks very good it
looks like we're um doing well in terms
of achieving our targets and kobe is
having uh less of an impact which is uh
very positive and the recommendation
seems sensible in terms of the um the
social media moving that one on it's as
you say very well established now so
i'm happy to move recommendations is
there a secondary
thanks cancer keeper and uh council
rented you have a question on the paper
yeah it was just just really an update
just just on the eco 20 the um review to
ensure tourism is a focus uh just it is
just worth putting in there that we had
an intern who's been
who's really done some of the work that
we wanted anyway um and i think it'd be
worth just
putting that into this
in terms of the resource we've had a
really really useful resource
uh in in tourism uh she her contract was
being extended had been extended as well
so she's really sort of carried
continued the work that we would have
had for the post holder so that it is
worth mentioning
thanks council really i was going to
point that one out myself actually i
wondered whether we'd already achieved
that one but i suppose it depends on the
wording it talks about more additional
resources isn't it so
yeah i think it's a full-time resource
yeah
but she's doing a great job okay
brilliant thank you for that
um okay so we'll we've been moved and
seconded and we'll move to the vote
although it's in favor
okay that's carried thank you
uh and the next item is funding to
voluntary and community organizations
and this is the summary of the outcomes
for the
uh for the previous uh financial year so
i'll hand over to councillor powell
who's going to talk us through this one
thank you chair
well as you know every year
the council funds a number of
excuse me
voluntary sector organizations to uh
help our residents in a number of ways
um to ensure that
our council taxpayers money is being
spent wisely
we of course
check the outcomes of the projects and
the organizations that we follow
um
[Music]
the investment in these uh voluntary
organizations is measured in accordance
with the current council plan
uh with targets and uh as
has already been mentioned by car
to assist vulnerable and disadvantaged
households
um
this monitoring ensures value for money
as we aim to make sure that voluntary
organizations reach as many households
as possible
by
the boost to these resources that the
council gives
more than 18 000 households were helped
in the year under review
that is less than normal um as gathers
pointed out
uh the lack of face-to-face meetings
because of the pandemic and the
lockdowns has been a significant factor
um but nevertheless i would like to
commend to you the remarkable
achievement of these voluntary
organizations
uh who have really stepped up to the
plate for us and kept things going
despite uh despite the difficulties that
they they have
um
and as part of uh what i want to say
this afternoon i think
monitoring and helping these
organizations
with advice and assistance
unlike
i'd like to thank the council's
partnership team
particularly steve lee and uh chris
burdette they are really our credit to
the council and the work that they do
in helping all these organizations
so therefore i would uh ask members
simply to note the context of the report
which is all we're required to do at
this stage
thank you chair
okay thank you very much council powell
i'm happy to uh to second that um
counselor pal can't actually move the
motion so we think we need someone in
the room
i've forgotten about that sorry thank
you
i'll happily move uh the recommendations
then and uh councillor kenyon
if you if you can second brilliant um
yeah just to echo the comments that
council powell's made it's obviously um
it's been a difficult year for all
organizations but clearly these um
many of these organizations that we've
been supporting have been doing a
fantastic job
in supporting their communities and
absolutely echo the comments around the
partnerships team and all of their work
on this so
yeah happy to happy to move it forward
so we'll move to a vote all those in
favor
okay that's carried
uh thank you for that so the next item
is urgent items
um of which there are none
and exclusion of the
of the present public
i move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them
of exempt information as defined in part
one of schedule 12a to the local
government act 1972
uh as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
um
so yeah i think that's that covered in
that
thank you do you have to vote on that
sarah never remember
yeah okay all those in favor
you